who are you
and no one
follow me nothing mustard in our word
I'll show the dark side
I don't know your name
Finn what George
I'm right
you might need this
hey youtubers is Charlie so new Star
Wars footage we see a lot more Princess
Leia her daughter is even in this clip
so let's bring it down if you're
watching this in the United States then
you may have seen this during shondaland
which is like this ABC block of
programming it's a bunch of like
female-driven shows they showed some
weird stuff during scandal then they
posted this but with whatever new
footage is new footage biggest things
first thin downward striking with the
lightsaber attacking a stormtrooper
which looks like it has a charged weapon
that's blocking the lightsaber now
because the stormtrooper that he's
fighting looks just like a normal
stormtrooper I'm wondering if in the
time since Return of the Jedi the people
that know about Jedi and lightsaber
technology have tried to adapt to it
they did reveal a bunch of stuff about
Luke JJ Abrams was talking about how he
fits into this movie thematically he
says that Luke is more of a myth people
like ray the younger characters don't
know a lot about him but the first order
actually indoctrinates their soldiers
during childhood and teaches them about
the evil Luke Skywalker who destroyed
the wonderful Empire so you I mean you
the idea if you ever saw that Seth Rogen
filmed the interview they go to
interview Kim Jong hyung in North Korea
and all the people are led to believe
these really hilarious lies about him
it's kind of the same thing the first
order is doing to their new
stormtroopers so Finn who does start out
as a stormtrooper has been taught about
the evil Luke Skywalker growing up but
Rey's character who's been living in
isolation kind of like the way Luke
Skywalker grew up on Tatooine doesn't
know anything about Luke Skywalker she
has absolutely no idea who he is JJ
Abrams actually even even made some
jokes about the classic stormtroopers
versus the new stormtroopers he's like
you know in the classic trilogy they
were kind of there to stand around and
get shot not being able to shoot any of
the heroes absolutely the worst shots
with the blaster they couldn't hit the
side of a Star Destroyer if they tried
they actually tried to inject a lot of
pathos and character into these
individual stormtroopers that we meet
during the force awakens so you learn
about why everyone hates Luke Skywalker
so much
and speaking of Finn he is supposed to
have a certain amount of history with
Poe Dameron here my guess is is that he
helps pod Ameren escape pogue gets
captured by kylo Ren interrogated from
what you see in this scene then at some
point he has to escape Finn is probably
part of that but the other big thing is
we see Leia here in her control room
she's being called general in
these new films obviously she stopped
being a princess the minute Alderaan was
blown up but people have been talking
about it like it's a big thing really
it's not that big a thing most of the
younger people in the film grew up in a
galaxy without Alderaan so they would
have never thought of her as princess
they did say that there's like this
funny moment in the film when someone
calls her princess and it causes like
this big stir like she gets really upset
you can imagine if no one knows her as
princess who would be calling her
princess obviously it's gonna be Han
Solo but we almost see the full original
Trinity here you see general Leia I
guess we should call her now you see Han
Solo Threepio with his red arm
mysterious red arm and then in the
background here you see Billie lourd
that's actually Carrie Fisher's
real-life daughter whenever it was
announced that she was gonna be in the
film everybody wondered if she was gonna
be a young Princess Leia that's not the
case she's just playing a background
character in these resistance scenes but
there was also some confusion about this
Rey Han Solo scene where he's like here
you might need this he's handing her the
blaster that she fires at kylo Ren here
I did see some new sights reporting this
as a lightsaber it is not a lightsaber
she's gonna have that staff for most of
the film until she gets this blaster
here's my question for you guys though
do you feel like the 30 years it's been
since Return of the Jedi is enough for
this first order like the remnants of
the empire which is being called the
first order to indoctrinate a bunch of
people against Luke Skywalker it's
definitely in keeping with the spirit of
something that the Empire would try to
do but oh I almost forgot we actually
learned some new stuff about mass kanata
from JJ Abrams as well as Supreme Leader
Snoke from Andy Serkis so Maz Kanata
she is a thousand years old which is
moving into Yoda territory she's not a
member of Yoda species but she's been a
pirate for a long time so when she is
saying I've seen your eyes before it's a
much grander statement than it sounds
like the thing about Andy Serkis is
character he said that Supreme Leader
Snoke is the leader of the first order
he is a really big character he's
completely CG like he's way too big way
way bigger than a normal person he has
no connection to anything that happened
in the previous films and he has this
really strange weakness he's vulnerable
in a really unusual way which makes it
sound like he stays inside like a Vader
chamber like you know Vader's special
chamber but I'm not expecting to see a
whole lot of them in episode
seven somatically I think it's gonna be
like the Luke Skywalker thing where it's
like you see them a little bit towards
the end of the movie then they become a
much bigger thing in Episode eight but I
am really excited especially to see Finn
just like hacking away at with his
lightsaber and they did confirm that
does come from Maz Kanata they said that
this scene is her handing it off to Leia
so that makes me wonder if she's the one
to hand it to Finn but that's just
speculation in other related cool Star
Wars happenings there's a cool
behind-the-scenes special that's gonna
be on the Disney Channel tonight if you
get it definitely check it out it's
supposed to be on at 8:30 I'll totally
do a video for it if it's not too long
I'll try to post the whole thing on my
channel and don't forget to giveaway
still going on it's it's two imax
tickets for Episode seven all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video I'll just all
announced the winners whenever I post
that next Star Wars video bye guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my episode 7 playlist with all the
trailers I've been posting and you can
click here for the latest Jessica Jones
trail that I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you